jérôme cahuzac avec le président de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
nationale et surtout en ce moment
monsieur finances monsieur finances
publiques monsieur fiscalité et budget
de françois hollande est l'invité de
cette émission de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous la
première réforme que le candidat
socialiste lancera s'il est élu c'est la
réforme de la fiscalité d'où
l'importance évidemment des réponses que
vous allez apporter ce soir à nos
questions jérôme cahuzac elles sont très
nombreuses avec dans un instant hervé
hasquin de l' agence france-presse
et puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
d'abord d'abord bien sûr la sécurité
évidemment elle fait un retour en force
dans la campagne mais elle n'est pas la
priorité des français selon bv a le
pouvoir d'achat la croissance l'emploi
bien sûr la dette également les impôts
l'école arrive loin devant est de nature
à rassurer le camp hollandais car on le
sait il le dit lui-même d'ailleurs
nicolas sarkozy la sécurité c'est mon
sujet c'est mais marqueur
c'était son sujet il s'agissait
probablement de ces marqueurs mais force
est de constater que s'il avait pu
rencontrer auprès des français un
certain succès entre 2002 et 2007 depuis
qu'il est président de la république sur
ce sujet de la sécurité nicolas sarkozy
a déçu et il a déçu parce que chacun a
conscience pour lui même ou pour le
quartier dans lequel il vit de ce que
nous nous savons de l'évolution de la
délinquance en france
ce quinquennat aura été un échec si l'on
en juge par l'augmentation des
agressions aux personnes
l'aggravation des escroqueries notamment
au détriment des personnes âgées sur ces
sujets là des prêts dans la république a
échoué bon vous nous a fermé ce soir que
la gauche est sortie de son angélisme
sur ces sujets là on en est vraiment sûr
vous êtes tous sur la même ligne
ça fait bien longtemps que j'avais bien
une sortie de l'angélisme en la matière
et je si vous en doutez je vous engage à
aller voir ce qui se passe dans les
villes qui sont dirigées par des maires
socialistes et vous verrez que la
sécurité dans ces municipalités et une
politique prioritaire et pour laquelle
les élus socialistes font preuve d'une
très grande fermeté
en tous les cas si françois hollande est
élu il y aura des renforts de policiers
de gendarmes et il y aura des renforts
également dans l'administration de la
justice ça a été chiffré c'est un sujet
très important car depuis 2007 il y a
douze mille policiers et gendarmes de
moins sur le terrain nous avons donc un
président de la république qui
prétendait faire de la sécurité sa
priorité mais qui au service de cette
priorité ne trouvait rien d'autre de
mieux à faire que de diminuer les moyens
humains sans policiers cents gendarmes
sur le terrain on n'a pas de bonne
politique de sécurité on nous en promet
t 1000 de plus par an alors vous avez
chiffré vous cette mesure d'autant qu'il
faut peut-être aller plus loin encore en
raison de ses inquiétudes nouvelle
peut-être le programme de françois
hollande indique clairement ce qu'il en
est il y à 2 milliards et 100 millions
de francs prévus pour des emplois
supplémentaires dans l'éducation
nationale dans la police dans la
gendarmerie et dans la justice
et ces mesures là sont clairement
financées dans le programme de françois
hollande 2 milliards d'euros 2 milliard
cent millions d'euros ces mesures là
sont clairement chiffré dans le
programme de françois hollande c'est
d'ailleurs le seul des candidats qui à
ce jour se présentent aux suffrages des
français et qui a publié un programme
avec à la fois des dépenses et des
recettes les deux étant chiffré et
d'ailleurs les deux ayant été évalué par
des organismes indépendants qui ont
donné quitus à françois on y reviendra
on y reviendra évidemment il ya toujours
débat sur les chiffres qui sont avancés
vous le savez j'aime que le sac débat
sur ce sujet là et avoir répondu avec 6
qui avait chiffré ces projets ont fait
recette
je considère qu'il ya peu débats dès
lors que l'on considère que la plus de
90%
les chiffres donnés par françois
hollande ont été validées par des
organismes indépendants et vous citez
l'institut montaigne le ton avec lequel
vous avez les mains tu m'aimes
polémiquer mais qui reconnaît
effectivement que vous mettez tout sur
la table
même si la république il m'a débat
intérêts sur des champs technique
d'accord on va pas entrer dans les
détails c'est un peu compliqué ouais la
tendance est tout rend souvent à de
surévaluer les recettes est sous-évalué
les dépenses vous le savez
vous êtes à pour surveiller peut-être on
est on est validée par cet institut
indépendant qui n'est pas
particulièrement proches ni du parti
socialiste françois hollande met
d'ailleurs au volant proches de
personnes en tout cas certainement pas
de nous plutôt libérale et cet institut
a validé à plus de 90% les chiffres que
nous avons pu donner je reviens sur les
questions de sécurité notamment sur l'
après toulouse et montauban est ce que
vous partager l'indignation de nicolas
sarkozy qui s'expriment sur différents
points d'abord à l'encontre de ceux qui
ont critiqué les forces de l'ordre puis
l'action des services de renseignement
et là c'est le ps qui directement disait
j'ai pas eu le sentiment que mes amis en
tout cas françois hollande critiquer ni
les policiers du raid
je crois qu'il leur a même rendu hommage
et il y avait là une forme de justice à
leur rendre hommage car le raid a été
créé par un ministre de l'intérieur
socialiste il s'agissait de pierre joxe
et puis il m'a plutôt semblé que
certains amis de nicolas sarkozy faisait
reproche à françois hollande de ne pas
avoir voté un certain nombre de lois sur
la sécurité intérieure présentée à
l'occasion de ce quinquennat il se
trouve que si le fou meurtrier a pu être
identifié c'est grâce à une loi du 31
octobre 2001 une loi votée sous l'
empire du gouvernement de lionel jospin
et par une majorité à laquelle
j'appartenais une loi que d'ailleurs le
député nicolas sarkozy n'avait pas voté
donc on vous répond oui mais la vraie
loi c est l adaptation de 2003 c'est
celle là qui a permis bien tous nos
autres querelles de campagne bref tout
le monde ya mis du sien
la courte doter les forces de police et
surtout la justice des moyens permettant
à tous d'enquêter pour identifier et
neutraliser le plus vite possible ce
genre d'individu et plutôt que de se
renvoyer la balle il a fait ça il n'a
pas fait ça convenons que en la matière
chacun a pu contribuer à l'intelligent
ment à ce que et la justice et la police
et les moyens pour enquêter et
neutraliser les individus de cette
nature françois rebsamen le président du
groupe socialiste au sénat parle d'un
fiasco dans cette opération est ce que
vous prenez ce mot est ce que vous
dénoncez détails
la question n'est pas de savoir s'il ya
eu fiasco il pas il est probable en tout
cas on peut l'espérer que la justice
fera toute la lumière
sur celles et ceux qui ont pu l'aider
cet individu à commettre ces actes
insensés qui ont blessé la nation est il
là est l'essentiel
maintenant j'aimerais que la justice
fasse son travail comme il se doit sans
interférence politique même si je
comprends bien que ces interférences
seront difficiles à éviter de la part
d'un pouvoir en place qui se soumet au
jugement des français et de mai de la
part des accusateurs aussi qu'on trouve
dans les rangs des parlementaires
socialistes alors qu'elle accusateurs à
propos de quelles accusations sur les
soupçons sur les failles le fiasco donc
de cette opération dont il ya t'il des
arrière pensées bonne idée parce que
vous
je pense que le coach en question tout
le monde sera d'accord pour dire que la
justice doit maintenant travailler le
plus sereinement possible
mais comme vous l'avez vous même
remarqué ce sujet est essentiel car il a
blessé la nation mais ces sujets
sécurité à rio peut être au premier plan
peut-être en 2007 certainement en 2002
ne sont plus au premier plan car nos
concitoyens ont le sentiment que ce
thème là fut exploité de manière peut
être à dhuisy outrancière maloney dre
semblablement par certains qu'en vérité
tous les républicains sont d'accord pour
convenir que la sécurité c'est une des
premières libertés que nous devons
garantir à nos concitoyens et qu'une
fois qu'en réalité nous sommes d'accord
sur ce sujet ce qui compte c'est la
croissance le chômage le pouvoir d'achat
l'apurement de la dette la place de la
france dans le monde ce sont ces sujets
là sur lesquels me semble-t-il nos
concitoyens auront à choisir le futur
chef de jour bien sûr eu notre
indignation exprimée aujourd'hui par le
président candidat à l'elysée qui a reçu
donc les forces de l'ordre qui ont
participé à cette opération à toulouse
sur l'éventuelle
diffusion des vidéos bon finalement à la
chaîne al jazeera ne va pas les diffuser
et puis également sur la requête
éventuelle du père du tueur qui voulait
porter plainte contre la france là il ya
évidemment une indignation collective et
consensuelle oui il n'ya pas débat entre
les uns et les autres sur ce sujet nous
formons tous des voeux pour que cette
vidéo morbide et malsaine ne soit jamais
publié ces images là sont infiniment
détestable pensons à la peine des
familles voir ces images là serait
insoutenable insupportable quant à aux
intentions du père peut-être aurait-il
dû s'occuper de son fils un peu plus tôt
et éviter d'en parler aujourd'hui
comme l'a dit françois hollande il a
perdu une occasion de se taire cet homme
là nicolas sarkozy et françois hollande
sont au coude à coude dans les sondages
au premier tour françois hollande
conserve une confortable avance pour le
second jérôme cahuzac
l'un des phénomènes c'est quand même la
montée en puissance de jean luc
mélenchon qui apparaît comme le
troisième homme est ce que ça vous
inquiète plus du tout va franchement ça
n'est ni inquiétant ni surprenant est en
tout cas satisfaction moyen long pagne
que votre candidat il fait une campagne
qui correspond à son style jean luc
mélenchon souvenez vous c'était le bruit
la tempête le fracas et la fureur bien
jean-luc mélenchon canalise des colères
qui sont très vives aujourd'hui chez nos
concitoyens qui n'en peuvent plus de
souffrances économiques et sociales il
canalise ses colères par un verbe qui
est très haut et très fort il veut peser
sur le candidat hollande il veut que
franchir son programme c'est son droit
c'est son droit qu'est ce que vous allez
faire répondre par exemple ils disent
aux gens restent clairement dit ce qu'il
en était à terre par exemple est qu'une
fois que le premier tour était passé il
fallait choisir entre l'un et l'autre
encore présent au second tour et que
naturellement lui attendait à ce que par
exemple jean luc mélenchon et ses amis
soutiennent sa candidature dès lors
qu'il serait au deuxième tour et dès
lors que l'on soutient la candidature de
ceux de françois hollande on approuve
naturellement son programme conditions
c'est non non pardonnez moi ce qui
compte en la matière c'est la parole du
candidat françois et celle de jean-luc
mélenchon et les vocations
dit regardez moi je crée 14 nouvelle
tranche d'imposition pour une plus
grande progressivité de l'impôt vous
vous proposez une seule tranche
supplémentaire alors là il ya un débat
est manifestement c'est un point
essentiel à la fois pour jean luc
mélenchon et pour le parti communiste
j'ignorais que la fiscalité fut un point
essentiel pour jean luc mélenchon mais
laurent l'a répété ce matin c'est
quelque chose d'intéressant
quoi qu'il en soit si jean luc mélenchon
est au second tour celui qui doit
affronter nicolas sarkozy
il sera normal que ceux qui veulent la
défaite de nicolas sarkozy se rallie à
jean luc mélenchon et jean luc mélenchon
n'aura pas à négocier quoi que ce soit
avec quiconque et au demeurant on lui
demanderait de négocier de son programme
qu'il le refuserait bien françois
hollande est dans la même position et il
a clairement indiqué que si c'est lui
qui est au 2e tour face à nicolas
sarkozy ce que je crois il demandera aux
uns et aux autres de se prononcer sur sa
candidature et sur son programme et la
majorité présidentielle se constituent à
ce moment là par le soutien à un
candidat et par l'adoption d'un
programme
c'est très clair c'est une fin de
non-recevoir en démocratie et en tout
cas dans la pratique de la vème
république et de l'élection
présidentielle on ne négocie pas sur un
bout de table ou sur un coin de cuisine
les choses entre les deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle ça ne s'est
jamais fait de la sorte et je ne crois
pas que cela se fera ainsi dans un mois
voilà le message sera sans doute reçu 5
sur 5 jérôme que la réciprocité nous
l'acceptons a priori bien sûr bien sûr
mais vous pariez évidemment sur
l'hypothèse de la présence de françois
hollande au second tour
naturellement été très surpris comme
jean luc mélenchon paris sur sa présence
à lille c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs
plus et d'ailleurs je ne demande pas à
jean luc mélenchon de négocier quoi que
ce soit avec quiconque du parti
socialite ce side aventure c'est lui qui
était présent au deuxième tour
donc dès lors que l'on accepte que la
même règle pour tout le monde je ne vois
pas ce qu'il y aurait de choquant là
vous aviez très surpris il ya quelques
temps par l' annonce surprise évidemment
françois hollande de taxer à 75 % les
revenus au delà de 20 millions d'euros
il il paraît que françois hollande
prépare une nouvelle mesure choc là vous
êtes au courant vous n'allez pas être
pris de vitesse
seule la parole du candidat compte et un
langage un peu de patience patience
patience mes yeux deux mesures dans les
cartons
on va y revenir avec hervé hasquin de l'
agence france-presse
dans un instant qui va reprendre toutes
ces questions fiscales mais d'abord avec
jérôme rabier on voit justement la
promesse budgétaire du candidat
socialiste délicate affaire d' équilibre
difficile en période d'austérité de
pouvoir réenchanter le rêve français on
chiffres ont très tôt ses 60 mesures
françois hollande prend le risque de se
faire critiquer 45 milliards de recettes
fiscales pour 20 milliards de dépenses
nouvelles
c'est l'objectif affiché mais pas facile
de ne pas en rajouter en période
électorale et l'institut dans
l'entreprise proche du patronat s'est
chargé de chiffrer les nouvelles mesures
annoncées par françois hollande début
mars
ça a commencé lundi 5 mars par un
discours sur l'enseignement supérieur
il ya eu des annonces faites pour la
journée de la femme
des annonces est aussi sur secteur
associatif et puis la semaine s'est
terminée par une émission sur capital
sur m6 avec des propositions sur pouvoir
d'achat je passe le détail de ces
mesures qui sont nombreuses mais on
arrive à un total entre 3 et 5 3
milliards d'euros 3,5 milliards qui
viennent s'ajouter aux dépenses déjà
annoncées pourtant françois hollande est
plutôt jugée crédible après avoir
travaillé depuis deux ans sur les
questions de fiscalité
l'institut montaigne plutôt libérale
juge même ses dépenses budgétaires et
fiscales équilibrée même si sur les
rentrées fiscales il manque pour
l'institut kata 5 milliards d'euros à
trouver
on salue l'effort du candidat socialiste
vous avez des programmes très très
détaillée aussi chez d'autres candidats
mais qui sont moins précis dans la
faisabilité ou non économique dans les
conditions de réussite économique
ensuite on tombe pas sur les mêmes
chiffres que mais je crois que ça aussi
ça fait partie de la marge
d'interprétation la marge d'erreur et
puis et opus peut-être de la différence
d'appréciation sur les mesures tiraillé
entre le côté social démocrate
gestionnaire et une aile gauche plus
utopiste
le candidat socialiste joue sur les
questions économiques et budgétaires sa
crédibilité pour terra nova fondation
proche du parti socialiste
le subtil équilibre est trouvé d'un côté
il faut donner une vision de long terme
est un projet qui ré enchanter la
politique et de l'autre il faut pouvoir
tenir le réalisme la crédibilité parce
que
quand vous êtes à la tête d'un pays cd
cd vraie manette que vous gérez avec de
nouvelles recettes supérieures aux
dépenses annoncé le candidat socialiste
promet de revenir à l'équilibré
budgétaire en 2010 est presque un voeu
d'abstinence pour un parti socialiste
souvent taxé d'être trop dépensiers
bonsoir hervé question ici et pour une
première question justement sur
l'équilibré budgétaire de votre projet
il ya de nouvelles mesures qui arrive
très un rythme soutenu par exemple la
petite enfance ou la numérisation des de
la france 100% de réseaux numériques à
travers la france
tout ça c'est du coup ça fait 5 6
milliards c'est vous êtes à l'aise avec
103 5 milliards ces coûts
supplémentaires et en dehors de 3 à 5
milliards je rappelle que le budget du
pays chaque année utile hors
prélèvements sur recettes ses 270
milliards d'euros est ce qu'on est
capable de dégager entre le 1 et un an
et demi pour cent du budget inutile du
pays
pour financer ce type de projet il me
semble que poser la question c'était
évidemment y répondre nous ne sommes pas
dans le cas d'espèce dans la situation
d'autres candidats je pense au candidat
sortant qui lui annonce des mesures
beaucoup plus onéreuse sans jamais avoir
indiqué ni comment ils les financerait
ni surtout comment il rétablir l
équilibre des finances publiques sauf
pour énoncer un certain nombre
d'affirmations péremptoires mais non
étayées non mais on viens de l'entendre
quand même le site montagne dimanche
grosso modo 4 milliards de recettes
fiscales
c'est votre avis aussi vous je crois que
vous avez travaillé assez étroitement
avec eux donc vous connaissez grâce à la
transparence
ils ont une première critique à laquelle
j'ai répondu ils m'ont donné acte pour
la moitié des recettes que moi j'estime
et qui les oublier et je pense qu'un
jour ils me donneront pacte pour la
deuxième moitié dont il est vrai que ça
n'est plus un écart de 4 à 6 milliards
d'euros qui nous sépare mais un écart de
2 à 3 et sur ces 2 à 3 je pense que ils
conviendront assez vite
en réalité cet écart là n'existe plus
avec les indications que j'ai pu leur
donner donc en fait
en fait on pour la première fois un
programme et précis il est chiffré et ce
chiffrage est validée par un institut
indépendant à plus de 95%
françois hollande est le seul candidat
enfin vous avez dit 90% tout à l'heure
mais bien autour de noms ou des mois
autour de 10% de marge d'erreur c'est 5
à 10% avant que je donne les précisions
dont je viens de vous parler c'est
désormais à plus de 95% et je maintiens
que françois hollande dans la
compétition qui nous occupe est le seul
candidat qui a élaboré un programme
aussi précis chiffrés de manière aussi
rigoureuse et dont les chiffres ont été
validés je le répète après 95 % par un
organisme indépendant
on attend que les autres candidats
fassent preuve de la même rigueur mais
je crains que l'on attende un peu
longtemps
bon le plafonnement des quotient
familial c'était
un souvenir un peu délicat pour le ps ça
s'est passé très bien est ce que
maintenant vous êtes sûr de vous sur la
manière de procéder
les choses ont été écrites aujourd'hui
le plafond du quotient familial ses 2300
36 euros vous le savez ce plafond
françois hollande propose de la bc non
poids à tel ou tel chiffre
comme annoncé mais à 2000 euros cela
veut dire que pour une enveloppe celle
du quotient familial de 13 milliards
d'euros par an on en dise très 400 à 450
millions pour améliorer le montant de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
c'est-à-dire la location qui bénéficie
vial des enfants aux foyers les plus
modestes de notre pays prétendre comme
le fait le candidat sarkozy corps
distrayant milliards d'euros d'une
enveloppe de 13 milliards on supprime
celle ci démontre s'il en était besoin
que le candidat sortant est trop souvent
dans l'outrance que dans le jugement
objectif françois chérèque ce matin
jeudi dans les colonies fierro il faut
forfaitisés ce quotient familial
vous voulez plafonner ce que c'est une
bonne idée cette ce format propositions
de françois hollande est d'abaisser le
plafond de 2336 à 2000 euros c'est ça
donc que nous ferons prétend que le
quotient familial est supprimé au nom de
cette mesure encore une fois c'est un
jugement outrancier peu surprenant chez
le candidat sortant mais néanmoins
outrancier et renforcer l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire me paraît une nécessité
à un moment où le pouvoir d'achat
connaît l'évolution que l'on sait
défavorable surtout pour les foyers les
plus modestes de notre pays fornay très
loin quand même des 1700 euros de smic
que proposée par jean luc mélenchon là
vous fait grignoter un petit peu par
votre gauche
est-ce que vous avez une réponse à
apporter à ceux qui seraient tentés de
voter pour jean luc mélenchon c'est
quand même ça maintenant l'enjeu 1700
euros
vous connaissez le smic aujourd'hui
combien ça allait très bien non non je
vous pose la question d'avancer et 1390
euros par mois et c'est parfait
je vous laisse je vous fais grâce des 8
euros bruts c'est-à-dire 9 euros 22 leur
embrouille plus comme vous le savez le
smic est un salaire horaire il n'est pas
un salaire mensuel donc en fait le vrai
chiffre du smic c'est 9 euros 22 brut
bon alors c'est pas un quiz sur les
chiffres de l'économie mais quand j'ai
senti qu'on servait à ce qu il était
comme l'institut montaigne la mention
parfaite ou presque bi très bien des
gens ça leur est néanmoins resté 10700
votre question relative au programme de
jean luc mélenchon et non une fin en soi
appartenait au parti socialiste il en
est parti il a créé son propre parti
politique il est soutenu par le parti
communiste qui n'est pas le parti
socialiste bref nous avons le candidats
d'autres partis que le parti socialiste
qui propose d'autres choses que coriace
parti socialiste leur droit mais ça
dérape à ce que ce parti a fait ses
propositions que inévitablement ces
propositions la devrait devenir les
autres j'ai déjà répondu tout à l'heure
pour vous indiquer à vous mais je le
précise hervé hasquin que le soir du
premier tour la majorité présidentielle
doit se créer autour d'un candidat ou de
l'autre jean luc mélenchon et ses amis
auront le choix soit de soutenir nicolas
sarkozy ça me surprendrait soit de
soutenir françois hollande je l'espère
ça ne soutenir ni l'un ni l'autre
renvoyant les deux dos à dos je ne crois
pas qu'il privilégiera cette hypothèse
qui serait d'une certaine manière un non
choix
je pense donc qu'il appellera à voter
françois hollande et je le souhaite
ardemment et dès lors qu'il appelle à
voter pour françois hollande il accepte
qu'il le veuille ou non le programme de
françois hollande est un programme
présidentiel au moment où se crée la
majorer pris la majorité présidentielle
c'est pas une discussion qu'on a sur un
coin de table je te donne fait si tu me
lâches cela c'est pas comme chat
l'amendement
s'il est au gouvernement il l'est pour
une politique est définie par le chef de
l'état est sous le contrôle d'une
majorité parlementaire celle qui sera
sorti des urnes
après les élections législatives de ce
point de vue jean luc mélenchon a passé
un accord son parti a passé un accord
avec le parti socialiste pour que ces
candidats disposent de quelques
circonscriptions avec quelques
espérances de gains à eux de concrétiser
ses espérances de gains dans le cadre
d'une alliance bien
prises avec le parti socialiste mais au
sein de la majorité présidentielle qui
sera celle de françois hollande
et avec le programme de françois
hollande oui alors 25% vous avez proposé
pour revaloriser un petit peu le pouvoir
d'achat des classes populaires vous
proposez 25% d'augmentation de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire ça fait
un peu pâle figure si j'ose dire aux
côtés des 1700 euros neveu mélenchon
quand même est-ce que penser de la sorte
d'abord à gauche est un concours à
dépenser le plus écouté je refuse de
m'inscrire dans cette compétition les
concours moi j'ai entrepris pour moi
n'est pas le concours ni la compétition
intéressante aujourd'hui on parle que du
budget d'état mais là des entreprises et
des salaires versés par exemple vous
avez parfaitement raison
alors parfaitement raison ce que l'on
sait c'est que le taux de marge des
entreprise est historiquement bas ce que
l'on a constaté d'ailleurs c'est que ces
entreprises ont des pistes au taux de
marge très bas avaient fait de
l'investissement
la variable d'ajustement pour continuer
à verser les dividendes je pense que
nous serons d'accord avec jean luc
mélenchon pour éviter que ces politiques
là ne se reproduise en allemagne ce
n'est pas le versement de dividendes qui
a été privilégiée mais l'investissement
c'est plutôt cela qu'il faut s'efforcer
d'obtenir des entreprises car on sait
bien que ces investissements là dès lors
qu'il serait réalisée permettrait les
emplois demain donc nous avons nous
avons avec jean luc mélenchon quelques
différences il n'y en avait aucune
il ne serait pas candidat c'est aux
français de trancher à l'occasion du
premier tour et ce sera encore aux
français de choisir quelle majorité
présidentielle ils veulent conduite par
quel futur chef de l'état
et parmi ces français qui auront à
choisir il y aura jean luc mélenchon
hors jeu ne croit à son sujet c'est la
deuxième fois dans cette émission que
vous êtes très clair et très nette
jérôme cahuzac alors il ya quand même le
calcul avec l'électoral jean luc
marchand progresse dans les intentions
de vote au second tour et ceux qui
baissent et bien c'est le pourcentage de
ses électeurs prêts à se reporter sur
françois hollande
ça doit vous interpeller quand même il y
aura un discours à tenir à l'égard de
ses électeurs en leur indiquant
clairement en leur indiquant clairement
que selon la règle je crois éprouvé de
la vème république et l'élection
présidentielle au premier tour on
choisit au deuxième on élimine et aux
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon à ce
qu'ils auraient fait confiance au
premier tour
d'indiquer qu' au deuxième tour il
souhaite éliminer c'est aussi simple que
cela va bien alors jérôme cahuzac un
autre grand sujet du quinquennat écoulé
qui sera peut-être aussi celui du début
du prochain camp du quinquennat c'est
celui du bouclier fiscal finalement
finalement vous le rétablissent et je
n'ai pas ce sentiment là mais vous allez
magasiner votre caisse qui bon c'est à
dire que pour les plus riches
85% un plafonnement plafonnement
d'ailleurs qu'est ce que vous mettez
dans les 85 % même si le plafonnement
qu'on appelait le plafonnement rocard
était la même chose que le bouclier
fiscal qui fut le bouquet villepin puis
legoupiller sarkozy si les deux choses
étaient identiques pourquoi avoir gardé
le plafonnement rocard quand le bouclier
sarkozy fut instauré si les deux ont été
conseillés ou plutôt si le premier a été
conservé quand le premier était
instaurée c'est que leur finalité ne
sont pas exactement les mêmes d'abord
les montants ne sont pas les mêmes et
ensuite j'ai une différence de fond
entre les deux c'est que le bouclier
sarkozy inclus et les impôts locaux
c'est que jamais le plafonnement rocard
n'a prévu de faire ce que vous voulez
faire jacques jusque sur le fond
personne ne souhaite instaurer de
prélèvement confiscatoire personne n'a
jamais voulu certes et quoi qu'on fasse
on vous le rappelle rien oui enfin
encore que la jurisprudence à laquelle
il est fait allusion et suit ses études
et débats juridiques nationaux
commencent alors les 75% le soir et des
tons mais au delà je n'en suis pas
certain mais au-delà de cet argument
juridique non je n'en suis franchement
pas d'un bon mais au contraire il ya une
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
qui indique au regard de l'impôt sur la
fortune
il n'y a pas de chiffres plafond au delà
duquel la mesure serait
inconstitutionnelle mais au delà de ce
débat juridique est intéressant mais qui
n'est pas selon moi l'essentiel du débat
il y à un débat de nature politique il
faut savoir assumer
nous sommes en économie de marché et
vouloir instaurer des prélèvements
confiscatoire est totalement antinomique
avec l'économie de marché dans laquelle
nous sommes car cela reviendrait à
plafonner ou voulant limiter à priori
l'activité ou l'initiative économique et
ça n'était absolument pas ce qu'il faut
faire
donc il est normal qu'il n'y ait pas de
prélèvements confiscatoire en revanche
il est normal que certaines
rémunérations excessives soit désormais
dissuader vous avez vu comme moi
la nouvelle qui est tombée ce matin le
patron de publicis percevra cette année
plus de 22 millions d'euros 22 millions
d'euros
c'est le patron d'une association vous
si vous venez au pouvoir pour se passer
d'abord notre argent
c'est tellement une bonne nouvelle pour
lui mais sagna millions 15 millions
d'euros de rémunération du contrat tout
contre vous tombez bien raconter les 16
millions d'euros de bonus différés on va
compter sa rémunération
on va compter la retraite qu'il touche
on va compter les autres rémunérations
accessoires le total fait 22,3 au
logement d'abord il toucherait cette
année votre jugement moral jambes quand
même bien je ne suis pas là pour faire
de la morale simplement pour indiquer
quoi que on ne peut être contre
l'enrichissement personnel à partir du
nom de cet enrichissement est la
contrepartie d'une utilité sociale
objectivement constater il crée des
emplois
les gens créent beaucoup et schofield à
ces objets est ce que oui mais déjà
ville que lui le défi dit alors ça a été
voté par les actionnaires bien sûr c'est
bien connu on sait comment ça se passe
bref est ce que est ce que réellement on
peut penser qu'un homme quel qu'il soit
même avec le talent de maurice lévy qui
n'en est pas dupe les mêmes autres aviv
est ce que vraiment on peut estimer que
cette année 2012 maurice lévy a une
utilité sociale dont la juste
contrepartie serait de percevoir 22
millions d'euros eh bien je ne le crois
pas bon j'ajoute que ça crée un
sentiment d'inégalité puissant etc
montesquieu qui disait qu'il faut faire
cesser le désordre des inégalités
l'inégalité dans la répartition de la
richesse produite quand elle est à ce
point est un désordre et ce désordre
il faut y mettre fin voilà c'est clair
et net là encore et sa vie ne sert pas
l'intérêt général
en pratique on mais quand il n'a pas une
rémunération que son utilité sociale
peut justifier
c'est donc un désordre celui que dénonce
et montesquieu et quand on est quand
responsabilité des affaires d'un pays
les désordres nous faut dix mettre fin
en première question est alors dernière
question pour la fusion de l'impôt sur
le revenu de la cg c'était le grand
cheval de bataille de hollande où
l'entend pas un peu moins sur ce sujet
on dit que ça reste un objectif assez
flou
on verrait est ce que cette enterrés ou
est ce que vous allez faire il ya quatre
étapes pour fusionner ces deux impôts
harmoniser les assiettes harmoniser les
modes de prélèvement fixé le tout est
indiqué quelle partie de cet impôt est
réservé au secteur social
ces quatre étapes là doivent avoir un
début le début c'est l'harmonisation de
l'assiette c'est ce que nous faisons
alors vous avez la réforme faire
totalement ce serait qui est annoncée
c'est la réforme de l'assiette de
l'impôt sur le revenu afin de rapprocher
celle-ci autant que faire se peut de
l'assiette de la csg ce ne sera pas
encore le cas mais une bonne partie du
chemin aura été fait et je vous rappelle
que concernant le prélèvement à la
source et la cour des comptes elle même
qui a indiqué que cette politique là
cette mesure-là présenté beaucoup moins
d'intérêt qu'elle n'aurait présenté il
ya de cela quelques années pour une
raison simple c'est que à l'impôt sur le
revenu tous les français sont
aujourd'hui mensualisés pour le verset
est donc source présente peut-être moins
d'intérêt qu'à l'époque dès lors on peut
s'interroger sur ce que serait la
nécessité impérieuse de fusionner ces
deux impôts dans les deux trois ou
quatre ans qui viennent au regard de
l'intérêt que cela comporterait il me
semble que le principal intérêt c'est
rétablir la justice et ont rétabli la
justice
avec cette grande réforme de l'impôt sur
le revenu qui ne sera pas une réforme
anodine croyez le bien
cette réforme qui commence à harmoniser
les assiettes entre les deux impôts
cette réforme qui fera continué le
capital autant que le travail car il
n'est pas normal
il n'est pas normal hervé hasquin
qu'aujourd'hui en moyenne le capital
contribuer deux fois moins que le
travail ressources de l'état si on a
révisé la sienne on les rapproche on et
elles seront toujours pas identique donc
c'est pas une fusion c'est un
rapprochement
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui a été annoncé
vous parlez de la loue car depuis la fin
du mois de janvier
c'est toujours ce que françois hollande
est alors quand même je reviens non pas
sur mélenchon babou dit la grande
réforme fiscale il n'y aura pas de
tranche d'imposition entre 45% et la
nouvelle à 75% dans votre programme dans
votre projet dans cette affaire avec une
question de loi de finances nous sommes
dans un projet présidentiel avec des
lignes à définir avec un projet à
définir le projet présidentiel de
françois hollande c'est faire cesser le
désordre de telles inégalités dans la
répartition de la lettone
qualités pratiques qui présideront droit
s'apprêt à acadia ja ce dessin cette
volonté là on verra cela après après
banque dans les états en tous les cas
dans votre projet actuel on passe d'une
tranche à 45% à 75 %
là on peut s'interroger sur la
progressivité de l'impôt environ on a
tout dit sur le sujet si vous voulez
bien
merci hervé seringe arnaud de public
sénat va nous rejoindre dans quelques
minutes juste après cette enquête de tam
traduit par une enquête fiscale avait
une enquête sur vous comme mais jérôme
cahuzac
jérôme cahuzac alias monsieur budget de
françois hollande ne plaisante pas avec
les chiffres
il ne pratique pas non plus
l'improvisation même si cela dessert son
candidat par exemple lorsque françois
hollande annonce par surprise qu'il veut
taxer à 75 % les français qui gagnent
plus d'un million d'euros par an
monsieur budget potes en touche
vous m'interrogez sur une déclaration
que pour ma part je n'ai pas entendu
puisque contrairement à tous les autres
qui sont ici autour de cette table je
n'ai pas besoin de regarder une émission
de françois hollande pour savoir pour
qui je voterai en l'espèce pour lui donc
je ne sais trop que vous dire sauf que
je fasse attention parce que chaque fois
qu'il vient chez vous on commence les
missions en m'interrogeant sur une
déclaration qui n'est pas vu le trouvais
pas sous-entendre contente de vous
piéger je vous fait réagir et d'accords
ou fin de vie est journaliste et moi
j'essaye de vous répondre le plus
sérieusement du bien sur 7
bon double fonction à la fois président
1 pouces la commission fonctions un peu
institutionnels et puis porte-parole de
françois hollande sur ces sujets peut
parfois le mettre en difficulté
on l'a vu sur la question des 75% ce
jour là jérôme cahuzac a peut-être eu le
réflexe de sa fonction officielle mais
ce n'est pas son habitude au palais
bourbon il s'est plutôt fait remarquer
par sa rugosité et ses attaques portées
à la majorité une personnalité beaucoup
moins consensuel que didier migaud son
prédécesseur à ce poste
jérôme cahuzac sera plus enclin à
contesté parfois violemment tel ou tel
aspect de la politique de la majorité
aujourd'hui bien positionnés pour
devenir ministre du budget en cas de
victoire de la gauche
jérôme cahuzac s'est pourtant formés sur
le tas en matière de finances publiques
lui ne vient pas du sérail sciences po
l'ena il y a encore dix ans cet ancien
chirurgien esthétique de formation ce
serait plutôt imaginé ministre de la
santé alors conseiller technique jérôme
cahuzac a notamment préparé la fameuse
loi evin sur l'alcool et le tabac le
dossier s'enliser moi j'avais la volonté
de faire aboutir ce projet et ça montre
bien d'ailleurs le caractère de jérôme
cahuzac c'est quelqu'un qui s'engage
c'est quelqu'un qui croie
d'abord à des valeurs ce qui fonde son
engagement personnel et puis quand il
est saisi d'un dossier il le mène
jusqu'au bout à l'époque la loi evin
privilégier la bonne santé des français
plutôt que celle des finances publiques
les priorités en depuis un peu changé 80
sur l'ambiance a été violent voilà
perrine tarneaud est avec nouveaux
périls bonsoir on vient de revoir cette
séquence sur le plateau de france 2
autour des 75 % dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure ça a été un grand moment de
solitude pour vous rendre intéressant
sur le plan politique intéressant
pourquoi
qu'est ce que vous en avez tiré comme
leçon à la fois preuve de sang-froid pas
s'affoler
on sentait quand même composite est très
pris au dépourvu non j'ai déjà pris au
dépourvu puisque je connaissais la
mesure pour en avoir pris connaissance
sa mise avant d'entrer sur le plateau
visiblement sa vie n'était pas suffisant
pour développer des arguments vous avez
remarqué mètres carrés dans vos réponses
à leurs marques et depuis le début de
cette évolution
mais françois hollande lui a été très
sec parce que quand il a été interrogé
sur votre surprise il a dit baye est
comme ça il l'a appris cinq amateurs
actuellement c'est exact l incident ne
se reproduira pas ce que ça n'avait pas
l'air françois hollande ça des doigts
pour que ça ne dépend pas que de moi
mais est-ce que vous en avez parlé avec
lui la blessure s'est expliquée ya pas
de problème patriarcat fait quelque
chose
non absolument pas pour revenir sur
maurice lévy et ses fans a d'ailleurs ça
n'a rigoureusement aucune responsabilité
dans le fait que je n'ai pas été informé
à temps de cela dont il ya aucun
problème on me dit souvent la parole du
candidat d'abord ben voilà sur le fond
c'est exactement ça c'est lui qui doit
nouer un lien avec les français
donc c'est seul ça parle compte c'est
lui qui a été élu à l'occasion des
primaires mais pas aussi c'est à lui de
faire de choix et c'est de là d'autres
dont je suis le défendre cette parole
ces mesures ensuite finir force
jérôme cazes ik-june cayzac pas bon pour
revenir sur maurice lévy et son bonus de
16 millions d'euros dont on parlait à
l'instant
l'actionnaire principal de publicis
c'est la famille
de la femme de l'ancien garde des sceaux
robert badinter la famille d'elisabeth
badinter ya une responsabilité là cet
actionnaire principal à côté vous lui
poserez la question en ce moment là
j'étais à paris j'ai des amis là non ça
vous je sais bien je regrette d'ailleurs
mais c'est ainsi mais une responsabilité
de l'actionnaire principal vous voulez
vous en venir parce que vous êtes
choqués que de grandes personnalités de
gauche en l'occurrence elles donnent
leur aval à ce genre de rémunération que
vous jugez ne correspondant pas à
l'utilité sociale de celui qui leur foi
cécilia contradictions elle et chez
d'autres elle n'est pas chez moi donc
c'est pour cela qu'il faut interroger
on a compris à les autres affaires
l'intervenant cours avec patrice de
maistre l'ancien gestionnaire de fortune
de la famille mme bettencourt qui reste
derrière les barreaux alors derrière
patrice de maistre derrière eric woerth
il ya forcément nicolas sarkozy c'est ce
que la justice semble penser ça dit bien
ce sens je n'ai pas d'éléments qui me
permet de porter d'appréciation certaine
je ne crois pas que un juge décide à la
légère d'incarcérer un individu en
espèces monsieur de maistre
il semble que le juge tout sonne
monsieur de maistre d'avoir contribué à
un financement illégal d'activité
politique et en l'espèce de la campagne
de nicolas sarkozy en 2007
je dis bien il semble car je n'ai aucun
élément qui permet d'avoir d'opinion
définitivement la matière s comme est ce
que comme eva joly vous demander à
nicolas sarkozy de renoncer à son
immunité et de venir s'expliquer devant
les juges il est très surprenant que
madame joly qui est magistrat demande à
nicolas sarkozy de renoncer à ce à quoi
il n'a même pas le droit de renoncer
tant qu'il est présent de la république
il est couvert par une immunité qui lui
fut conférée par une décision du conseil
constitutionnel et même madame eva joly
bien qu'elle soit magistrate n'a pas la
possibilité de délier de prière de la
république d'une situation décidée par
le conseil constitutionnel
eva joly qui stagne à 2 % des intentions
de vote dans l'indifférence sondage
qu'on peut lire en ce moment est-ce que
ça rend totalement caduque l'accord qui
a été conclu entre europe ecologie les
verts et le parti socialiste pour les
élections législatives
ça ne doit pas rendre caduques les
thèmes que les écologistes et les verts
porte et qui sont des thèmes je crois
tout à fait essentiel même si je
constate que cette campagne ne les
aborde pas même si j'observe que ces
thèmes là les français il semble a
priori peu sensible quant à l'accord qui
a été conclu
tout a été dit sur ce sujet là l'encré
sèche et j'imagine qu'elle sera
respectée
vous l'imaginez mais ça sera pas le cas
vous le savez il y aura des candidats
dissidents venus du parti socialiste
félicitations ces dissidents seront déjà
été exclu du parti socialiste parce que
c'est la règle dans notre parti ensuite
comment empêcher un homme ou une femme
d'autant qu'il s'agirait de députés
sortants n'ayant pas démérité comment
les empêcher de se présenter s'il estime
qu'ils ont un bilan à faire valoir et un
projet à défendre ensuite intéressant
devant celles du parti socialiste à ceux
qui se présentent contre un candidat
investi par le parti socialiste sont
quasi automatiquement exclus de ce parti
c'est une règle qui n'a jamais souffert
des dérogations
on vous entend j'en cahuzac député de
l'émission effectivement comme l'était
et août à la rochelle vous êtes très
carré les réponses sont très formaté
quand on est à bryant n'est pas la
pression de la crise n'est pas finie
quand on est présent la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale est ce
qu'on est forcément formaté après pour
le ministère des finances pour bercy non
c'est un choix politique qui ne dépend
que du président de la république en
fonction de situations du moment où de
politique à mener et c'est cette
adéquation entre le moment les
politiques à mener et la confiance qu'il
peut avoir ou ne pas avoir envers telle
ou telle c'est cela qui fait que le
président décide de confier telles
responsabilités at-elle autres plutôt
que à une autre responsable il est en
vie la question n'est pas de savoir si
on a envie si vous voulez savoir de quoi
j'ai envie j'ai envie console en gagne
ça oui ça vraiment pas l'ombre d'un
doute mais vous vos propres ambitions
post 2012
il faut s'interdire de penser tant qu'on
n'a pas gagné on sinon on finit par
faire des bêtises et elles doivent
s'exprimer pendant une campagne
électorale vous le savez bien jérôme
cahuzac
la seule ambition qui s'exprime c'est
celle de françois hollande pour gagner
car françois hollande je m'inscris dans
cette ambition là je fais plus tout ce
que je peux du mieux que je peux là bas
ça c'est important parce que le train
part voit peut-être parfois n'est ce pas
d'espacé suffisant mais je fais tout ce
que je peux dire mieux que je peux pour
aider françois hollande en cette
victoire dit lui-même observe les gens
qui le soutiennent qui le défendent
comme vous ce soir et il ya des gens qui
seraient
durant la campagne donc c'est un critère
important vous l'avez en tête forcément
je n'ai pas le sentiment mais je ne veux
pas non plus à paraître présomptueux
mais j'ai pas le sentiment d'avoir
changé par rapport à ce que j'étais il
ya deux mois deux ans ou en début de
mandature
j'ai toujours tenté d'avoir un langage
de vérité étayée par des éléments
objectifs et vérifiables
j'ai toujours défendu des valeurs celles
qui sont les miennes et qui m'ont fait
adhérer au parti socialiste j'ai choisi
de soutenir la candidature de françois
hollande lors de l'élection primaire qui
l'a opposé à d'autres candidats dont
martine aubry
j'ai toujours assumé mes choix et je
continue et si j'ai une envie c'est
celle de voir françois hollande gagné
pour que le changement intervienne -
docks la fidélité bernard tapie ancien
ministre de gauche votent pour nicolas
sarkozy en 2012 votre réaction
entre entre son ministère à gauche et
l'annoncent qui vote nicolas sarkozy
s'est passé un petit événement qui a vu
bernard tapie se faire attribuer par
l'état
un certain nombre des millions d'euros
dont il lui reste à ma connaissance
entre 220 et 230 pour couler des jours
heureux
je dirais que bernard tapie est la
reconnaissance du ventre c'est bien en
revanche choisir takieddine votre à lui
pour françois hollande c'est un
intermédiaire libanais qui est mise en
examen dans la sphère dans le dossier
karachi
je suis comment dirais-je 6 voix contre
françois hollande c'est son droit et
dans le secret de l'isoloir chacun fait
ce qu'il veut
maintenant vous m'interrogez en réalité
sur les motivations de monsieur
takieddine alors vaut-il pour françois
hollande parce qu'il est convaincu par
son programme ou vaut-il ne vaut-il pas
pour monsieur sarkozy car il a le
sentiment d'être laissé tomber parce
qu'il a aidé poser la question c'est
peut-être y répondre une dernière
question sur une des propositions hier
soir de françois hollande il propose que
les 4 à 6 % des meilleurs élèves de
terminale est un droit d'accès dans une
classe préparatoire est ce que la
diversité passe forcément par
l'instauration de quotas
c'est ce qui s'est passé à sciences po
l'initiative de son directeur monsieur
descoings et ça a été un succès et donc
quand une politique originale en
laquelle bien peu croyaient d'ailleurs
au départ quand cette politique
originale s'avère une politique
couronnée de succès je crois qu il y a
tout intérêt pour tout le monde à la
généraliser et c'est dans cette
généralisation que françois hollande
s'inscrire je pense à raison donc une
généralisation des quotas qui pourrait
s'appliquer
plusieurs étapes les cinq politique des
quotas on peut aussi appeler ça une
politique de la deuxième chance qui
consiste à permettre à des élèves qui
n'ont peut être pas le le brio que l'on
est en droit d'attendre des lèvres
entendant des classes préparatoires de
néanmoins bénéficié de cette formation
là parce qu'on leur donne une deuxième
chance en france
nous ne sommes pas un pays où nous avons
l'habitude la pratique de la deuxième
chance
je pense que c'est un gâchis
extraordinaire il faut savoir donner une
deuxième chance aux gens enfin les
départs vraiment nouvelles non plus
puisqu'elle est déjà mise en oeuvre par
12 le général des idées formidablement
original
peut-être faut-il d'ailleurs s'en méfier
mais dès lors que cette politique a
réussi
vouloir la généraliser sans être une
idée originale est une bonne idée
merci perrine meyer locaux jérôme
cahuzac d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui
la semaine prochaine les invités de
preuves par 3 seront jean pierre
raffarin et nathalie arthaud de lutte
ouvrière mais je précise pas dans la
même émission évidemment un
il ya un double rendez vous merci à vous
à la semaine prochaine donc